how do you convince people who are  center left and center and even  conservatives and like squish  conservatives as you call them that  objective reality of men being men and  women to women is the hill to die on if  we're not going to make that stand on  men  are not women  one of the most basic claims you could  make about  sex human nature and reality itself then  what are we going to make the claim on  we are not a movement of eggheads and  economists and so officers and  calculators we're not a movement of  spreadsheets or a movement of of men  with spirit and life and and  understanding that that life is about  more than our unfair fettered reason and  bumping up the gdp a little bit it's  about objective reality if we lose that  what the hell are we fighting for